bonjour à tous bonjour Marcel
c'est un peu une grande première pour
moi le tedix j'ai 38 ans je m'appelle
Cindy Dauvin caryoune nom de jeune fille
que j'aime bien garder quand même j'ai
deux enfants en bas âge et je suis ravi
d'être avec vous je vais vous parler de
thème qui me tient très à cœur et qui me
fait vivre au quotidien l'avenir
appartient aux entreprises
bienveillantes est-ce que ça vous parle
est-ce que la bienveillance vous parle
au quotidien dans le travail avec votre
famille vos amis est-ce que c'est si
facile à mettre en place et non alors
pour revenir un petit peu à mes origines
ben moi je suis fine boucher dans un
petit patelin en Bretagne qui fait pas
rêver 2000 habitants j'avais un père
bouché les cours du soir chez moi
c'était les devoirs vite fait et on va à
la boucherie apprendre à cuisiner et à
faire en sorte de t'avoir tenir une
boucherie
et en fait j'ai une révélation j'ai aimé
l'homme avec un grand H j'ai aimé ce
contact humain de venir chercher sa
tranche de jambon une fois deux fois
trois fois par jour pour avoir ce petit
mot réconfortant ou cette petite
anecdote qu'ils avaient à me raconter
sur leur chien leur chat peu importe
mais un truc qui s'est passé un truc
tellement puissant que je me suis dit en
fait je sais pas quoi faire de ma vie
parce qu'en vrai là boucherie c'est pas
si sexy quand même je t'exagérons rien
alors je me suis je vais faire des
études de commerce logique et puis le
côté international ça me plaisait bien
parce que du coup au revoir la Bretagne
je me voyais me balader amis partout bon
c'est pas totalement ce qui s'est passé
dans la vraie vie donc me voilà avec un
diplôme de commerce international à 20
ans
et là je regarde mon père j'y vais on
fait quoi bah il me dit export des
galettes ma fille ouais ok bon on va
peut-être réussir à faire mieux
qu'exporter des galettes bretonne quand
même donc je suis parti à la capitale et
ouais ça se disait la capitale à
l'époque ouais je sais ça fait un peu
vieille France mais c'était la capitale
donc me voilà avec mes deux valises et
puis des CV dans les mains en disant bah
ok je vais faire quoi ouais les agences
d'intérim ça me semble pas mal j'ai un
diplôme je suis plus cher c'est pas trop
mal ou cher intérim et puis j'ai
rencontré une première société qui m'a
fait confiance et je suis devenue
assistante commerciale
et puis bah moi j'arrivais toujours la
pêche parce que moi je suis née dans
cette bienveillance dans cette grande
famille donc c'est sûr que c'était mes
valeurs donc c'était assez facile pour
moi d'arriver avec la pêche puis là je
vais mes collègues surtout les
commerciaux il faisait la tête c'était
toujours des problèmes rien était facile
moi j'étais là vous savez rigolo de
bosser comme c'était mieux là boucherie
mais bon j'étais comme pas y retourner
exagérons pas et puis j'ai eu la chance
j'ai beaucoup travaillé trois ans après
j'ai une promotion je suis devenue
directrice commerciale donc à 23 ans
c'était plutôt pas mal mais surtout on
va on va donner des hommes avec un grand
H à manager mais en fait moi j'ai voyais
venir le lundi matin et j'ai toujours la
tête ils étaient toujours pas contents
mais là Cindy tu peux pas tu peux pas
décemment laisser les choses comme ça
alors j'ai un peu réfléchi j'ai rien
inventé je passais le lundi matin devant
chez mon primeur je récupérais quelques
fruits on dit chocolatine à Bordeaux
donc chocolatine on se faisait on se
faisait des petits déj en formel on
discutait de notre week-end et puis tu
voyais quand même que ça prenait un peu
la sauce pourquoi parce que bah en fait
combien d'entre vous vous êtes camarades
collègues est-ce que vous connaissez
vraiment bah non et donc si on se
connaît pas on peut pas vraiment être
bon ensemble on peut pas faire une
équipe
et puis sur un coup de folie ça m'arrive
assez régulièrement je dis on a tous des
voitures de fonction oui et si on
partait en séminaire mais le boss est
pas d'accord et on n'a pas de sous vous
inquiétez pas ça va bien se passer
j'avais la chance de gagner plutôt très
bien ma vie à l'époque à Paris et du
coup ils ont fait une location sur un
site et on a loué une maison Cap-Ferret
et on est tous partis là-bas
bon on va partager le même lit en
exagérant pas juste la même chambre mais
on va pas aller au resto bah non on n'a
pas de sous on va apprendre à cuisiner
ensemble
ah ouais
et en plus on va faire des activités bah
oui faut apprendre à se connaître donc
faut ce challenger et on va faire quoi
comme activité vous allez voir alors
j'ai rien fait d'extraordinaire j'aurais
fait manger des vers de terre pour le
côté rigolo on a fait du tir à la corde
bref mais néanmoins pendant 3 jours on a
vécu ensemble
et on a appris à se connaître trois mois
après mon directeur Cyril
m'appelle et il me dit Cindy tu peux
dire dans mon bureau je dis oui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a Cyril
tu as vu ce qui s'est passé dans les
trimestres
ouais ouais je crois des chiffres sont
très bons et dis ouais mais tu expliques
ça comment tu as fait quoi bah tu te
souviens pas on est parti en séminaire
on a créé un truc là de malade ah non
non mais Cindy c'est fini ça c'est
depuis quand les séminaires font qu'on
fait plus 30 % de chiffres ah mais parce
que ton capital humain c'est ce qu'il y
a de plus important ta boîte ah non mais
c'est pas mes valeurs moi j'ai pas que
ça à faire investir sur l'homme mais tu
as vu comment je vous paye déjà vos
commissions non on va pas faire ça ah
ouais et là j'ai 25 ans et je me dis
mince ça va pas ça va pas avec mes
valeurs ça va pas avec ce que j'ai
appris ça va pas une mon éducation alors
j'ai démissionné et pourtant le salaire
il était beau je vous assure et puis je
me suis mais qu'est-ce que je vais faire
25 ans je démissionne d'un poste avec
plusieurs zéro qu'est-ce que je fais
et en fait les Anglo-Saxons on est
toujours passionnés parce que je
trouvais que ça avait l'air chouette les
after hors qui a 17 heures vous savez en
France il y a un petit problème à ces
heures
quand tu pars ah mais tu as pris ton
après-midi non non je vais juste
chercher mes enfants je travaille juste
depuis 8h ce matin pas de problème alors
que quand tu fais un after-work aux
États-Unis ou en Angleterre tu continues
à parler de ton boulot tu donnes des
tips sur 5 ans tu as réussi ce dossiers
et toi comment tu as réussi il se passe
quelque chose donc j'ai adoré ça j'ai
adoré ce management à l'horizontale où
on n'est pas là pour faire des réunies
vous savez là où vous restez des heures
assis à écouter je ne sais même pas
pourquoi vous écoutez et vous êtes là on
vous demande là et puis donc un an après
moi je suis revenu alors là au taquet à
Paris
et puis j'ai trouvé un poste puis j'ai
expliqué tout ça puis on m'a regardé on
m'a dit ah ouais
donc j'ai fait avec les moyens du bord
si tu réussis à faire un tout petit peu
et puis
à 30 ans j'ai eu la promotion de mes
rêves qui était de gérer une filiale à
New York c'était l'époque que je
regardais ça que ça de City je me voyais
complètement devant Central Park gérer
50 bonhommes et là je me suis ça va être
génial bon entre temps je suis tombé
amoureuse et entre temps j'ai suivi
l'amour de ma vie à Bordeaux et donc
arrivé à 30 ans à Bordeaux bah plein de
convictions mais des boîtes bordelaises
c'était encore pire que Paris et là je
me suis dit mais Cindy tu es mal barré
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire alors entre
temps j'ai fait un bébé super belle
chose deuxième j'ai eu un Prud'homme
troisième harcèlement moral et quatrième
propos très très sexiste pour pas dire
autre chose et là j'ai dit
en vrai vous savez quoi il y en a marre
moi je vais acheter mon paperboard sur
leboncoin j'adore leboncoin à 10 euros
et je vais créer la boîte de mes rêves
et de celle que j'aurais voulu et je
vais être défenseur du bien-être au
travail et là mon mari regarde il fait
défenseur du maître au travail mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
et en fait ça porte un nom que je suis
sûr que la plupart de la salle ne sait
pas mais on va vous interroger j'ai créé
une société dans qui j'ai créé une
société dans la cuve était est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui la cuve était ça vous
parle
bravo vous êtes quand même pas beaucoup
à la mardi la cuve était qui a été dit
au travail et pourtant aujourd'hui
ça existe très fort mais c'est passé mis
en place dans les sociétés donc
qu'est-ce que c'est la qualité de vie au
travail c'est très simple c'est un
sentiment de bien-être là où vous êtes
dans votre entreprise vos conditions de
travail la bienveillance qu'on a envers
vous les points réguliers et ce qu'on
vous forme vous savez il y a un mot
qu'on entend parler et ce qui vous parle
le bord out
au travail en fait on oublie on a des
budgets de formation en fait on oublie
de prendre soin de vous et on oublie de
vous former mais un moment quand ça fait
cinq ans que vous êtes au même poste
vous avez envie d'évoluer et surtout
vous avez juste envie d'aller plus loin
et c'est ça les aussi les bilans de
compétences et toujours d'aller plus
loin
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui
la cuvt tout le monde dit ah non mais
moi j'ai de la cuvette à Paris ah bah
ouais j'ai des poufs de couleurs ah
ouais trop chouette oh non mais moi j'ai
le baby-foot dernier cri là mon bosse il
m'a mis ça là ça va donner deux ans de
survie dans la boîte ah ouais d'accord
on est loin on est loin on est loin on
est loin la chance c'est que Bordeaux
les baby-foot était pas arrivé fauteuil
de couleur non plus donc j'avais un peu
de marge il y avait rien en fait donc je
partais à zéro je partais à zéro avec
pas grand chose des convictions et des
chiffres et c'est ça que j'aimerais
échanger avec vous maintenant parce
qu'en fait il y a des chiffres qui sont
juste affolants mais quand on n'est pas
dedans bah on veut pas se rendre compte
des choses le pays des trois thématiques
que je vais aborder avec vous la
première les RPS qui devrait tous vous
parler et risque psychosociaux la
deuxième la génération passionnante des
milléniales et la troisième la marque
employeur
la première les RPS est-ce que vous
savez en 2021 combien de millions de
personnes ont été en burn-out plus de 25
millions si je suis sûr que dans la
salle tous autant que vous êtes vous
connaissez quelqu'un un parent un proche
qui a été burn out et vous savez quoi le
pire c'est qu'on croit que ça nous
arrive jamais parce qu'il y a du
caractère parce qu'on est fort parce
qu'on n'a pas envie que ça nous touche
mais c'est faux ça arrive d'un coup ça
vous prend et vous pouvez mettre des
années à vous en remettre mais ça le
chef d'entreprise il y a toujours pas
compris mais non mes équipes elles vont
bien bah oui elles ont le baby-foot
c'est sûr que faut pas être burnout ah
bah c'est sûr
et en fait
ça coûte un peu d'argent à l'état alors
vous allez me dire l'état on s'en fiche
un peu bah non parce que l'État c'est un
peu vous c'est un peu nous quand même
pour ceux qui bosse sans 7 milliards
d'euros c'est ce que ça coûte chaque
année l'absentéisme et donc le mal-être
au travail là on se dit 107 milliards
d'euros ah ouais mais ça vous parle pas
assez donc je vais vous donner un
chiffre par collaborateur demain vous
êtes tous collaborateurs dans des
sociétés ça coûte
13340 euros le coût du mal-être au
travail c'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé
c'est l'indice du maître au travail
c'est un chiffre de 2021
donc si on imaginait qu'un chef
d'entreprise un peu bienveillant et
intéressant se dit et si je m'étais
10000 euros
par an pour mes collaborateurs soient
bien au travail
bah ce serait quand même pas mal mais en
fait le problème qu'on a c'est que même
avec une crise sanitaire mondiale comme
on a vécu
on s'était battus pour le télétravail et
puis en fait en France on était on était
assez mauvais sur ça donc il a fait que
cette crise arrive une fois qu'elle a
été là bah ok bah pas le choix et les
équipes ont été performantes elles ont
été à la hauteur donc en fait la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
cet après-midi c'est est-ce qu'il va
falloir une énième crise qu'est-ce qu'il
va falloir faire pour qu'aujourd'hui le
chef d'entreprise prennent soin de ses
collaborateurs et surtout et envie de
prendre soin de vous et d'avoir donc
une meilleure productivité parce que
bien évidemment il n'y a pas investir
sur vous s'il y a rien qui se passe
derrière on est bien d'accord
et donc j'en arrive à cette génération
des milléniales ce qui m'a me passionne
totalement pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
s'en fiche du salaire vous savez quoi le
salaire il arrive en 3e position ils
peuvent avoir le meilleur package du
monde c'est même pas intéressant
qu'est-ce qui est intéressant
l'émission le poste les valeurs de la
société
alors aujourd'hui pour les séduire je
peux vous en parler parce que j'ai une
société et j'en ai 15 et il y en a
certains que j'ai voulu avoir et que
j'ai pas réussi parce qu'on peut pas
parce que parce que c'est la vie mais en
tout cas
c'est passionnant de se dire que c'est
eux et c'est cette génération de demain
qui va faire qu'on va pas pouvoir
accepter toutes les conditions de
travail qu'on nous donne aujourd'hui un
ticket restaurant c'est suffisant avec
un salaire avec un Smig et quelques
commissions non c'est pas suffisant mais
en fait sans les gens comme vous
aujourd'hui on va pas y on va pas y
arriver et ça c'est dur et pour ceux qui
sont parents ce qui est mon cas et
certains d'entre vous dans la salle on
se dit mais dans 20 ans nos enfants ça
va être quoi leurs conditions de travail
si aujourd'hui on fait rien pour tout ça
donc bah cette génération est fabuleuse
et en fait elle est fabuleuse pourquoi
parce qu'avant à l'époque de nos parents
et même moi je me renseignais pas du
tout dans la société dans laquelle
j'allais j'allais je voyais le poste oh
ça a l'air sympa le package est sympa
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes plus
de deux tiers à vous renseigner sur les
réseaux pour voir si cette boîte elle
vaut le coup est-ce qu'elle bosse sur sa
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
est-ce qu'elle prend soin de ses
collaborateurs est-ce qu'elle met en
place des actions comme du team building
est-ce qu'elle prend soin de VOUS
clairement
et du coup ben là les boîtes paniquent
un peu m'appellent Cindy là je crois que
sur la marque employeur je suis un peu
moyen ah oui ou de totalement moyen tu
ne fais rien pour tes collaborateurs
donc on peut pas me montrer du fake donc
nous arrivons à la dernière thématique
la marque employeur
et cette marque employeur en fait ce qui
est assez génial c'est que tout des
boîtes que j'accompagne aujourd'hui j'en
ai peu près une cinquantaine il y a un
chiffre qui est assez fabuleux c'est
Opinion Way qu'il a sorti c'est plus
235% de retour sur investissement
lorsque vous mettez une démarche
culbutée en place dans une société ça
veut dire qu'en plus de prendre soin de
vous lui gagne de l'argent donc tout le
monde est hyper gagnant donc pourquoi
aujourd'hui un chef d'entreprise est
capable de mettre des millions sur des
contrats de maintenance photocopieurs le
leasing le blabla et ne pas penser à
l'homme son capital le plus précieux et
donc c'est ma bataille c'est ma bataille
avec les équipes au quotidien de
démocratiser ça d'initier ça et nous
assure que c'est une vraie grosse
bataille donc pour la dernière anecdote
j'ai un chef d'entreprise bordelais qui
m'appelle il me dit Cindy je crois que
ça a pas des collaborateurs je sens un
peu burn out un peu déprimé tu crois
vous croyez parfois où tu dois que vous
allez pouvoir m'aider ok on va prendre
rendez-vous et puis là il sort son
chéquier je lui dis bah un chéquier mais
on n'a pas encore parlé de la méthode
bah si ils vont pas bien ça coûte de
l'argent combien il faut non ça marche
pas vraiment comme ça dans la vraie vie
je vais vous expliquer monsieur en fait
j'ai X à la pince qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on fait un diagnostic pourquoi on va
étudier ce que vos collaborateurs ont
besoin est-ce que vous-même vous avez
envie de leur donner on peut pas décider
juste comme ça au doigt mouillé oh bah
il leur faudrait des cours de sport il
leur faudrait des relaxation et là il me
regarde il me dit mais on va quand même
pas interroger les collaborateurs ah bon
pourquoi
ils ont déjà un salaire ils sont pas
malheureux chez moi et pourquoi on
dirait leur demander leur avis ah ouais
mince ah bah là ça va être compliqué
monsieur parce qu'en fait c'est pas dans
la démarche c'est pas l'ADN dit que
c'est la finesse d'accord bon bah
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah on fait rien
bonne journée au revoir et j'ai pas pris
le chèque il était beau le chèque mais
bon on passe à autre chose c'est pas
grave ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en 2030 il va avoir plus
de 40% d'indépendants imaginez 40%
d'indépendants pourquoi parce que les
entreprises arrivent plus à faire rêver
les collaborateurs et vous dans le
public vous êtes ceux qui demain allez
planter des graines dans chaque société
parce que vous n'allez pas accepter les
conditions de travail parce que vous
avez envie d'autre chose vous avez
besoin d'être d'autres choses pour être
bien au travail et si je peux pas moi en
tant que défenseur du être au travail
avec mes équipes comptez sur des gens
comme vous qui sont la génération de
demain je fais comment moi alors j'ai
pas le choix que vous demandez un peu
d'aide parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
vrai métier la qualité de vie au travail
qui est peu démocratisé aujourd'hui
informations c'est devenu quelque chose
d'essentiel on a des budgets pour ça la
QVT pas du tout on met des contrats de
maintenance qui sont indécents sur des
ordinateurs du leasing on refait des
flottes de voitures électriques
mais la cuvreté en fait on oublie et
pourquoi on oublie ça existe pas assez
donc j'ai besoin de toutes ces petites
graines que vous allez mettre partout et
je souhaite finir avec une citation
d'Henry Ford
les deux plus belles choses qui ne se
voit pas au bilan sont sa réputation et
ses hommes merci à tous et à toutes très
belles journées
[Applaudissements]